Could one badly judged email, one social media post or one period of struggling at work put your psychology career at risk before it's even begun? Most trainees will never face fitness to practice proceedings, but if concerns are raised, the process can feel frightening, confusing and surprisingly difficult to navigate. Today I'm chatting with legal advisor Nicholas Sturkling as we explore what really triggers fitness to practice concerns. What happens next and how to trainees can protect themselves without feeling terrified of making a mistake. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent and this is Psychology Actually.
一封判断失误的电子邮件、一条社交媒体帖子或一段工作上的挣扎，是否会在你的心理学职业生涯尚未开始之前就将其置于风险之中？大多数实习生永远不会面临“执业能力评估”（Fitness to Practice）程序，但如果有人提出担忧，这个过程可能会让人感到恐惧、困惑，且出奇地难以应对。今天，我将与法律顾问尼古拉斯·斯特克林（Nicholas Sturkling）进行交流，探讨究竟是什么引发了对执业能力的担忧。接下来会发生什么，以及实习生如何在不因害怕犯错而感到恐惧的情况下保护自己。我是玛丽安·特伦特（Dr. Marianne Trent）博士，这是《心理学其实》（Psychology Actually）。
Hi, welcome along to psychology. Actually, I'm Dr. Marianne Trent, a qualified clinical psychologist. I'm delighted to be welcoming back to the podcast, Nicholas Sterling, who is a legal advisor and the founder of NS Consulting. Hi, Nicholas. Hi, Mary Ann, it's nice to see you again. It's great to be back to discuss some really interesting points. Absolutely. And I should have said probably that you specialise in supporting people going through fitness to practice proceedings. Now something that people might not be aware of is that there are still fitness to practice proceedings going on and kind of standards that you need to maintain even before you become professionally regulated with the HCPC. And so what we're
嗨，欢迎来到《心理学其实》。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。我很高兴再次邀请到法律顾问、NS咨询公司创始人尼古拉斯·斯特林（Nicholas Sterling）回到播客。你好，尼古拉斯。你好，玛丽安，很高兴再次见到你。很高兴能回来讨论一些非常有趣的话题。当然。我应该提到，你专门支持那些正在经历执业能力评估程序的人。现在，人们可能没有意识到的是，即使在你获得英国健康与护理专业委员会（HCPC）的专业监管之前，也存在执业能力评估程序，并且有一些你需要维持的标准。所以我们发现的是……
finding is that people that are trainee clinical psychologists or the trainee paramedic, or whatever are coming up against fitness to practice proceedings and then finding, oh, I kind of fit in the middle of everything. So I'm not yet under HCPC. You know, I don't necessarily feel like the uni are on my side, maybe my placement supervisors and maybe not on my side. And they're feeling really quite unsupported. So what we're kind of looking to do is have a broad conversation around pre-qualified fitness to practice proceedings today, aren't we, Nicholas? I guess it's a really interesting area where people are really in a sort of grey zone where they don't have all the the regulatory support that you have when you're when you're with an institution for example the
那些临床心理学实习生、护理人员实习生或其他专业的实习生，在面临执业能力评估程序时，会发现自己处于一种尴尬的境地。我还没有受到HCPC的监管。你知道，我不一定觉得大学站在我这边，我的实习督导可能也不站在我这边。他们感到非常缺乏支持。所以，尼古拉斯，我们今天想要进行一场关于“资格前执业能力评估程序”的广泛讨论，对吧？我想这是一个非常有趣的领域，人们处于一种灰色地带，他们没有像在机构中那样拥有所有的监管支持，例如……
hcpc you you feel like you're you're in limbo a little bit so you you you're actually entitled to support from a university and at the same time they are regulating and making sure that they they adequately prepare professionals as they move forward pfdp process applies to both pre-regulated and regulated practitioners. Yeah, okay, but the HCPC aren't there for you until you're regulated, which puts you in a, I think, a tricky position. Yeah, I mean, I guess the kind of work I deal with at the moment when it comes to students or those who are beginning their training, trainees, is that they're not being regulated by the HCPC,
HCPC。你会觉得你有点处于悬而未决的状态。你实际上有权获得大学的支持，但同时他们也在进行监管，确保他们在专业人员前进的过程中对其进行充分的准备。PFDP（资格前执业能力）程序适用于未受监管和已受监管的从业者。是的，好吧，但在你获得监管之前，HCPC并不会为你提供支持，这让你处于一个我认为很棘手的境地。是的，我的意思是，我目前处理的关于学生或那些刚开始培训的人的工作，是他们并没有受到HCPC的监管，
therefore meaning that the standards that existed with the HCPC while incorporated into the university programs are not actually that it's not as clear to them actually what they're in time what they should be doing so I guess the first issue that I think we probably should look at is really the fact that there's no there's no national university FTP regime so we're well aware when we're practitioners with the HCPC or any other regulator the standards you have to adhere to and you also know enforcement of those standards is going to be with the HCPC or with the dental organisations or with the doctors. Now the problem is when we have students who are in this grey zone there's no single statutory body. There's no single guideline about how these processes
因此，这意味着HCPC现有的标准虽然被纳入了大学课程，但对他们来说，实际上并不清楚他们应该做什么。所以我想我们可能应该看的第一个问题是，事实上并没有全国性的大学FTP（执业能力）制度。当我们作为受HCPC或任何其他监管机构监管的从业者时，我们很清楚必须遵守的标准，我们也知道这些标准的执行将由HCPC、牙科组织或医生组织负责。现在的问题是，当我们的学生处于这个灰色地带时，没有单一的法定机构。没有关于这些程序如何运行的单一指南，
are run should you fall into FTP problems and I think that leads to some unfairness across the board in terms of different universities address FTP in a different way issues in relation to how they deal with neurodivergence in terms of how they deal with people of different backgrounds. That can depend on what university you go to. We know when we're in the HCPC, these are the standards, this is how it's regulated, this is how it's enforced. When you're in the university process, it is unclear and that can lead to a lot of anxiety with students, particularly when you combine that with being in the last year of your practice,
如果你陷入了FTP问题，我认为这导致了各大学在处理FTP的方式上存在某种不公平。在处理神经多样性问题以及处理来自不同背景的人的方式上，这可能取决于你所在的大学。我们知道，当我们处于HCPC监管下时，这些是标准，这是监管方式，这是执行方式。当你处于大学程序中时，情况是不明确的，这会导致学生产生很多焦虑，特别是当你把它与实习的最后一年结合起来时，
of your traineeship, for clinical psychologists, for example, if you're in the last six nine months, we all know how hectic that period is in your life. You obviously know that better than me, but you're managing family, work, caseloads, new, you know, new challenges that you've never faced before. And that's when things, you know, health issues can become a problem. That's when issues related to communication might be emphasized. And that's when you can fall of the FTP regime. So it's something that people have very little knowledge about this student FTP regime. Yeah, I think it is that ambiguity, isn't it? It's like you don't necessarily know where you're aiming for.
对于临床心理学家来说，如果你处于最后六到九个月，我们都知道那段时间你的生活有多忙碌。你显然比我更了解这一点，但你正在处理家庭、工作、病例量、你从未面对过的新挑战。那就是健康问题可能成为问题的时候。那就是与沟通相关的问题可能被强调的时候。那就是你可能陷入FTP制度的时候。所以这是人们对学生FTP制度知之甚少的事情。是的，我认为这就是那种模糊性，不是吗？就像你不一定知道你的目标是什么。
And I think it just reminded me of all of the different plates that I had spinning when I was a trainee. So I'd moved away from my family and my support systems to come and do the course. I was single when I first started the course. And then you're suddenly kind of trying to immerse yourself in cohort life. So with the people that are on your training in your year at the same time. You're also kind of slot into university life, so the demands of kind of academia and, you know, the interactions you might be having with your personal tutor and then actually attending university lectures and seminars as well. And then you've, of course, once you get to the right stage of things, you're starting placements and you've got work with your clients and then you've got work within your team, your MDT, and then you've got the actual client work as well. And then you've actually got your own life as well
这让我想起了我做实习生时同时要兼顾的所有事情。我搬离了家人和支持系统来参加课程。我刚开始课程时是单身。然后你突然试图让自己沉浸在同伴生活中。所以和你同年级一起培训的人在一起。你还要适应大学生活，学术要求，以及你可能与个人导师进行的互动，还要参加大学讲座和研讨会。然后，一旦你到了合适的阶段，你就要开始实习，你有客户工作，你有团队（MDT）工作，还有实际的客户工作。然后你还有你自己的生活，
that you've somehow kind of got to try and bolt into all of those. So obviously it's a lot without breaking any confidentiality. If we could just give like a couple of examples of the kind of fitness to practice things that you're seeing or that might be common to see for people pre-qualification, if you can, Nicholas. Yeah, I mean, you've summed it up perfectly about how that works, that stage of the trainees' completion of their course.
你必须以某种方式把这些都塞进去。所以很明显，在不违反保密原则的情况下，如果我们能举几个例子，说明你在资格前阶段看到的或可能常见的执业能力问题，如果你能的话，尼古拉斯。是的，你完美地总结了实习生完成课程阶段的工作方式。
So you can imagine the training is seeing the finishing line. And obviously this has been the buildup to their life's expectation, particularly in my experience with psychologists, because it's part of it becomes essentially an integral part of who they are. So they can see the finishing line. They're putting in all this hard work. And then the stress starts to become a major factor. Anxiety becomes a factor.
所以你可以想象实习生看到了终点线。显然，这是他们一生期望的积累，特别是在我与心理学家的经验中，因为它是其中的一部分，本质上成为了他们是谁的一个组成部分。所以他们能看到终点线。他们投入了所有的努力。然后压力开始成为一个主要因素。焦虑成为一个因素。
The fact that you're now taking on case load yourself becomes a serious factor, as I said. And if you have any, for example, issues with anxiety, is this with the communication, as I mentioned before, some neurodivergence, ADHD, autism, and whether it's some mental health issues, whether you've actually acknowledged that with the university, and some people have, some people have, some people have, some people have, some people have reasonable adjustment and they've done it, and they've acknowledged it that's part of the process, other people haven't. So this can be sort of accentuated and accelerate at this point in time. And in my experience with my diverse range of clients, it tends to be in this final phase,
你现在自己承担病例量的事实成为一个严重的因素，正如我所说。如果你有任何焦虑问题，正如我之前提到的沟通问题，一些神经多样性，多动症（ADHD），自闭症，以及是否有一些心理健康问题，无论你是否已经向大学承认了这一点，有些人承认了，有些人没有。有些人进行了合理的调整，他们做到了，他们承认了这是过程的一部分，其他人没有。所以这一点在此时此刻可能会被加剧和加速。根据我与不同客户群体的经验，往往是在这个最后阶段，
where things can really reach a point of becoming an FTP matter. So the types of issues that I deal with regularly often relate to communication. Now I think using that as the first example, and I'll move on to some others later. So communication can be how you deal with your supervisor. Communication can be how you're dealing with other students. Communication can be how you're dealing with clients. Now, anecdotally, and also in discussing with other colleagues, it's my experience that, you know, an over-proportionate representation of clients that I have are people who are
事情真的可能达到成为FTP事项的地步。所以我经常处理的问题通常与沟通有关。现在我认为以这个作为第一个例子，我稍后会谈到其他一些。所以沟通可能是你如何处理你的督导。沟通可能是你如何处理其他学生。沟通可能是你如何处理客户。现在，根据传闻，以及在与其他同事讨论时，我的经验是，我拥有的客户中，不成比例地代表了那些……
neurodivergent in this area. And while that's obviously not a topic for everyone, I think it's worth understanding for practitioners as well as people who run, who have trainees himself or, you know, people having difficulty with anxiety, people having students really having difficulty, some other, unmanaged health condition. So those that I see that have reached this stage, generally if it is not to do with a dishonesty, a clear dishonesty, they've plagiarized, they've they've stolen something. And you know, that their FTP matters and universities deal with those and they, you know, rightfully should not be admitted if they've really broken the rules. But those sort of clear-cut
在这个领域有神经多样性的人。虽然这显然不是每个人的话题，但我认为对于从业者以及那些经营、拥有实习生的人，或者那些有焦虑困难的人，那些学生确实有困难，或者其他未管理的健康状况的人来说，了解这一点是值得的。那些我看到的已经达到这个阶段的人，通常如果不是因为不诚实，明显的欺诈，他们抄袭了，他们偷了东西。你知道，他们的FTP事项，大学会处理这些，他们理应不被录取，如果他们真的违反了规则。但那些明确的……
cases are less interesting, I think, because we all know when someone's stolen a computer or someone's forged notes on a you know that's we don't want that type of person you know there may be some other issues involved but you know we can't accept that in terms of public protection but if you have someone who's communicating in their mind appropriately with staff but in the eyes of the staff there's a rudeness there's a lack of transparency that can escalate quite quickly and I think that's worth with people understanding that what can start off as being a communication issue and email inappropriate emails can when the process begins which is normally it's raised with the student there's a complaint
案例我认为不那么有趣，因为我们都知道当有人偷了一台电脑或有人伪造了笔记时，我们不想要那种人。可能涉及其他一些问题，但我们不能为了公共保护而接受这一点。但如果你有某个人在他们看来是在与员工进行适当的沟通，但在员工眼中，存在一种粗鲁，一种缺乏透明度，这可能会很快升级。我认为人们值得理解的是，最初可能是一个沟通问题，不适当的电子邮件，当程序开始时，通常是向学生提出投诉，有一个投诉……
raised and it goes to an informal meeting and that informal meeting is intended to solve that problem there might be some sort of improvement plan it's it's really how can we help the student that's the mentality of the university that how do we help the student past this stage but if the the student does not really have the same understanding of the issues that they may have presented, for example, if they are, have some neurodivergence or if they just view their whole incident differently, that can escalate because the way these matters stop at each step in the process, stage one, which is the informal process and then stage two, which becomes an FTP process, is the idea of insights. So you need to not only understand you've made a mistake, but have
提出并进入非正式会议，那个非正式会议旨在解决那个问题。可能有一些改进计划，这真的是我们如何帮助学生度过这个阶段，这是大学的心态，我们如何帮助学生度过这个阶段。但如果学生对他们可能表现出的问题没有相同的理解，例如，如果他们有某种神经多样性，或者如果他们只是以不同的方式看待整个事件，这可能会升级，因为这些事项在过程的每一步停止的方式，第一阶段，即非正式过程，然后是第二阶段，即成为FTP过程，是关于洞察力的概念。所以你不仅需要理解你犯了一个错误，而且要……
rectified and remediated that mistake. So issues of communicate, issues of health issues as well in terms of unmanaged conditions. They often lead to FTP matters. But I think the most interesting one is in terms of attitudinal issues, because what the universities will say is they will say, well, this person is not presenting as professional. And that's an interesting idea, which I'm sure you have some points about, in terms of what kind of psychologist are we trying to create?
纠正和补救那个错误。所以沟通问题，以及未管理状况下的健康问题。它们经常导致FTP事项。但我认为最有趣的是关于态度问题，因为大学会说，他们会说，这个人表现得不专业。这是一个有趣的想法，我相信你对此有一些观点，关于我们试图创造什么样的心理学家？
What do we want to go out into the world? Is the university educating and creating a particular type of psychologists or is it also, its perfunctory role is also to regulate? And they can sort of cross parts and they can become complicated. So, you know, are we trying to create a psychologist who fits a professional norm moving forward or are we trying to create someone who understands the various conditions that exist in psychology? There's something that I'm sure you can comment on. And there can be a bit of a diversion there. So FTP processes when someone is acting, what do I say differently, eye contact, can they actually, you know, are they masking, using a psychological term? And are they
我们想要什么样的人走向世界？大学是在教育和创造一种特定类型的心理学家，还是它的敷衍角色也是监管？它们可以交叉，变得复杂。所以，我们是在试图创造一个符合未来专业规范的心理学家，还是在试图创造一个理解心理学中存在各种状况的人？这是我相信你可以评论的事情。并且那里可能会有一点分歧。所以当某人表现出，我该怎么说，不同，眼神接触，他们是否真的，你知道，他们是在掩饰吗，使用一个心理学术语？他们是否……
going to be able to be an appropriate, safe psychologist? And I would argue that some of these people are being falling out of the FDP process and are being excluded from the profession because of whatever nuanced difference they may have. So that's a broad discussion that maybe you can comment on in terms of what type of psychologists we're wanting and whether whether the current system, the current regime is adequately preparing the profession for what these types of people are producing. Yeah, that is a really good point. And, you know, I do so much work around inclusion and how a psychologist don't all need
能够成为一个适当的、安全的心理学家？我会争辩说，其中一些人正在脱离FDP程序，并因为他们可能拥有的任何细微差异而被排除在专业之外。所以这是一个广泛的讨论，也许你可以评论一下我们想要什么样的心理学家，以及当前的系统、当前的制度是否在充分准备专业以应对这些人产生的影响。是的，这是一个非常好的观点。而且，你知道，我在包容性方面做了很多工作，心理学家并不都需要……
to look the same. And I'm aware that people might have been qualified for a longer period of time, might have different views around what, you know, is good enough for a psychologist or what the standards should be for a psychologist. and I'm really aware of the emerging literature around use of swearing, for example, and actually lots of clients can't find it really helps them let their guard down if a clinician will swear when they're talking to them. But obviously, you know, some people are sweary than others.
看起来一样。我知道那些可能已经获得资格较长时间的人，可能对什么是心理学家的“足够好”或心理学家的标准应该是什么有不同的看法。我非常了解关于使用脏话的文献，例如，实际上很多客户发现，如果临床医生在与他们交谈时说脏话，这真的有助于他们放下戒备。但显然，你知道，有些人比其他人更爱说脏话。
Some people find that very, very offensive. And I can imagine that if someone was very sweary, you know, in interpersonal meetings in the corridors and in MDT meetings, that might come across as antagonistic or rude. Well, in actual fact, for lots of people, it's just a way of punctuating almost and adding nuanced to discussions or really trying to connect with someone.
有些人觉得这非常、非常冒犯。我可以想象，如果有人在走廊里的个人会议和MDT会议中非常爱说脏话，那可能会显得具有对抗性或粗鲁。好吧，实际上，对于很多人来说，这只是一种标点符号，几乎是为讨论增加细微差别，或者真正试图与某人建立联系。
It isn't necessarily supposed to be offensive in the way that other people might view it as offensive. So I think even that is a good example about how there can be that miscommunication and maybe just different comfortability curves, I think, with, normal human behaviour? Absolutely. I think that's a great example.
它并不一定意味着像其他人可能认为的那样具有冒犯性。所以我认为即使是一个很好的例子，说明如何可能存在那种沟通不畅，也许只是不同的舒适度曲线，我认为，对于正常的人类行为？绝对是这样。我认为这是一个很好的例子。
You know, I personally, I'm Australian, so I grew up in a culture where, you know, it is a means of lowering barriers and that's just the way it is. You know, when you're in a familiar situation, when I'm with my parents, that we tend to, the language is different as when I'm in a court and it can often be a way of showing, hey, we're letting our guard down. So it's something I actually really identify with. In terms of Yeah, the communication norms and generally what norms are, and the reason why it's interesting to me as a legal practitioner is when FTP is about regulating accepted norms, which it is,
你知道，我个人是澳大利亚人，所以我成长在一个文化中，你知道，这是一种降低障碍的方式，事实就是这样。你知道，当你处于熟悉的情况下，当我和我父母在一起时，我们倾向于，语言与我在法庭上时不同，它通常是一种展示“嘿，我们放下戒备”的方式。所以我实际上非常认同这一点。关于……是的，沟通规范和通常什么是规范，以及作为法律从业者我为什么觉得它有趣，是因为当FTP是关于监管被接受的规范时，确实如此，
and we understand that there are certain standards that must be upheld, we need to also have some form of flexibility in there as well. So I know, for example, I have some clients of different ethnic backgrounds, different religions, and there has, While there's no overt discrimination, obviously that's a much more serious matter, there is a gentle, I would argue on the behalf of some universities, not all, and obviously these places are some of the forefront
我们理解必须坚持某些标准，我们也需要在其中有一定的灵活性。所以我知道，例如，我有来自不同种族背景、不同宗教的客户，虽然没有公开的歧视，显然那是一个更严重的问题，但我会代表一些大学争辩，并非全部，显然这些地方是一些关于如何处理歧视以及如何最好地装备学生的前沿……
thinkers about how we deal with discrimination and how to best equip students. So I don't want to label all, you know, universities are great places. That's the ones that eventually where they made, there may be some slight issues is, you know, accepting that some supervisors, some members of academia, outside of strict guidelines, you know, may not actually, may see norms in a slightly different way to, to some of these students or some of these trainees. Okay, so I mean, another example of this idea of norms and, you know, people's perceptions and I would argue their lived experiences,
思想者。所以我不想给所有大学贴标签，大学是伟大的地方。那些最终可能存在轻微问题的地方是，你知道，接受一些督导，一些学术界成员，在严格的指导方针之外，你知道，可能实际上并没有，可能以与这些学生或这些实习生略有不同的方式看待规范。好的，所以我的意思是，关于规范和人们的看法，以及我会争辩说他们的生活经历的这个想法的另一个例子，
using a case example I've had, is with a clients who, um, who felt excluded, from group work felt somewhat not discriminated because discrimination would obviously be a far more serious matter and then we're bringing in you know that that becomes a different level of complaint by the student but really feeling feeling that her experience as her in this example her but i've had other examples with a male their experience was that there was a lack of real recognition of how others felt others did others dealt with them during Ramadan in this particular example but I've had other examples where they were going through a personal issue and people were not actually communicating with them
使用我处理过的一个案例，是关于一位客户，她感到被排除在小组工作之外，感到有些没有受到歧视，因为歧视显然会是一个严重得多的问题，然后我们引入了……那变成了学生投诉的另一个层面，但真的感到，感到她作为她（在这个例子中是她，但我有其他男性的例子）的经历是，人们缺乏对其他人如何感受的真正认可，其他人如何在斋月期间对待他们（在这个特定的例子中），但我有其他例子，他们正在经历个人问题，而人们实际上并没有与他们沟通……
appropriately so that led to a distrust from the behalf of the client which led to lashing out at various people and led to an escalation very quickly so in terms of what you know this this client was this client was perceived as rude during this time period and again this may be a particular example but I think it sort of exemplifies the types of of issues that we're dealing with every, every trainee is an individual person with their own individual idiosyncrasies or their own individual cultural identity. And having a, you know, being able to listen to these people having their lived experiences as psychologists and not having a standard of particular psychologists that we all need to, that the university is trying to produce,
适当地，这导致了客户的不信任，导致了对各种人的抨击，并导致了非常迅速的升级。所以就你知道，这位客户在这段时间被认为很粗鲁，同样，这可能是一个特定的例子，但我认为它在某种程度上体现了我们正在处理的每一类问题，每一位实习生都是一个个体，有他们自己的个人特质或他们自己的个人文化认同。并且能够倾听这些作为心理学家拥有他们生活经历的人，而不是拥有一个我们都需要成为的特定心理学家的标准，大学试图创造的，
I think is something universities could strive towards a little bit more because they're the ones tend to fall foul of this FTP process, particularly in terms of universities. Yeah, yeah. And I want to just obviously give a nod to the fact that this is a really difficult, really stressful experience for the person that's undergoing the FTP investigation, but also probably for the people around them at having to raise that. This isn't something that people do lightly. And I think I've spoken publicly already that I had an experience on one of my placements.
我认为是大学可以多努力一点的事情，因为他们往往会陷入这个FTP程序，特别是在大学方面。是的，是的。我想显然要向这样一个事实致意，即对于正在经历FTP调查的人来说，这是一个非常困难、非常有压力的经历，但对于不得不提出这一点的周围人来说可能也是如此。这不是人们轻易做的事情。我想我已经公开说过，我在我的一个实习中经历过……
where at my mid-placement review, the question was, you know, is there a chance that the trainee might fail this placement? And the answer was yes. And I was like, I was horrified because it hadn't been communicated to me before. And my experience after that was that I really just found everything very difficult after that for a number of weeks until it was resolved. And it can kind of make you a little bit paranoid about whether other people are thinking that you're not good enough or whether other people have been part of this and having conversations about you and comparisons to other people that might be seeming to get it right more effortlessly. It isn't easy and it can impact on not just your work, but all of your outside life as well.
在我的中期实习评估中，问题是，你知道，实习生是否有机会无法通过这次实习？答案是肯定的。我当时感到震惊，因为之前并没有向我传达过。在那之后我的经历是，在问题解决之前的几周里，我真的觉得一切都非常困难。这可能会让你有点多疑，担心别人是否认为你不够好，或者别人是否参与了这件事，并在背后谈论你，并将你与那些似乎更轻松地做对的人进行比较。这并不容易，它不仅会影响你的工作，还会影响你所有的外部生活。
It isn't easy, isn't Nicholas? Absolutely. I mean, I guess that raises the greater question of what is the purpose of these universities. Are they there to support students or are they there? to protect the public. And I think obviously it's a twofold process. They're there to support students create the right type of professionals that we all want to see, particularly in, in, you know, vital roles such as psychology or across the healthcare profession. You're dealing with vulnerable people and your role is really important. But I guess in terms of how do we
这不容易，不是吗，尼古拉斯？绝对是。我的意思是，我想这提出了一个更大的问题，即这些大学的目的是什么。它们是为了支持学生，还是为了保护公众。我认为显然这是一个双重过程。它们是为了支持学生，创造我们都想看到的正确类型的专业人员，特别是在心理学或整个医疗保健行业等重要角色中。你正在处理弱势群体，你的角色非常重要。但我猜在如何……
support a student through a process, how do we support a student in whatever may be happening in their personal lives, whatever may be happening in their physical and mental health, while at the same time ensuring that wait a sec once they're they're finished with the process once the the trainees has completed their training they're going to be safe because that's really a really really important factor and i think everyone understands that and that's you know it's often a question that when i feel when i hear anger from clients whether there be trainees or whether they're qualified um registrants once they have an understanding of of the idea that the hcpc or in this circumstance that the university is that there they're
支持学生度过一个过程，我们如何支持学生度过他们个人生活中可能发生的任何事情，无论他们的身心健康可能发生什么，同时确保等一下，一旦他们完成了这个过程，一旦实习生完成了他们的培训，他们将是安全的，因为这真的是一个非常非常重要的因素。我认为每个人都理解这一点，这是（你知道，当我听到客户的愤怒时，无论是实习生还是合格的注册人员，这是一个常见的问题），一旦他们理解了HCPC或在这种情况下大学是……
performing a role that we all support which is protecting the public. It's about how that is actually managed and whether enough is done to to make sure that they're being supported through the process while also managing what is essentially future risk. That's the thing that's quite complicated to assess particularly for clients is when we're looking at remediation or insight in terms of an FTP matter it's not how you are now. You may have said I'm sorry for that particular issue. I will improve my communication, I'll improve my note taking, I'll improve my punctuality, my data protection, whatever it may be, but I haven't rectified, I haven't remediated the issue that exists. So that's managing that for universities is very difficult. I don't deny that, you know,
履行我们都支持的角色，即保护公众。这是关于如何实际管理这一点，以及是否做了足够的工作来确保他们在过程中得到支持，同时管理本质上是未来风险的事情。这是评估起来非常复杂的事情，特别是对于客户来说，当我们查看FTP事项中的补救或洞察力时，这不是你现在的样子。你可能已经说“我对那个特定的问题感到抱歉。我将改善我的沟通，我将改善我的笔记记录，我将改善我的守时，我的数据保护，无论它可能是什么”，但我还没有纠正，我还没有补救现有的问题。所以这对大学来说管理起来非常困难。我不否认，你知道，
they do their best. But I think when we have a system which is completely different across, I mean, not completely different, but varies across universities, not a standardized HCPC system, how students, trainees, various people, whatever stage of their training they may be, how they deal with the FTP process varies. So when I, and the reason why a lot of practitioners, in terms of legal advisors or solicitors, steer away from students is not necessarily because of the fact that students don't make, you know, they don't, they're not in need of assistance, it's that it's, you have different guidelines for every university.
他们尽力了。但我认为当我们有一个在各大学之间完全不同的系统时，我的意思是，不是完全不同，但各大学之间有所不同，不是标准化的HCPC系统，学生、实习生、各种人，无论他们处于培训的什么阶段，他们如何处理FTP程序各不相同。所以当我……而且很多从业者，就法律顾问或律师而言，避开学生的原因不一定是因为学生不制造（你知道，他们不，他们不需要帮助），而是因为，你对每所大学都有不同的指导方针。
So am I dealing with Reading today? am I dealing with Swansea? Am I dealing with and that that's to me feels a little bit unfair because you have a standardized system once they're registered but before registration it's not standardized and how well people are deal how well panels or universities deal with reasonable adjustment how well they deal with or how forcefully they enforce some of their say note-taking guidelines and these types of things vary and I'm not sure that's fair and I have colleagues who who work in the industry and deal a lot with students and they would argue that it's that it's a rogue world. I wouldn't go that far, but they'd argue that this is, it's a bit of a, it's in the
所以我今天是在处理雷丁大学（Reading）吗？我是在处理斯旺西大学（Swansea）吗？我是在处理……对我来说，这感觉有点不公平，因为一旦他们注册了，你就有了一个标准化的系统，但在注册之前，它不是标准化的。小组或大学处理合理调整的程度如何，他们处理或强制执行他们的一些（比如笔记记录指南）的力度如何，这些类型的事情各不相同。我不确定这是否公平。我有在行业内工作并处理大量学生的同事，他们会争辩说这是一个流氓世界。我不会走那么远，但他们会争辩说这是，这有点……
nether region there. You don't really know what you're going to deal with and that's not the right word. I enjoy, I enjoy the nether regions. Let's leave it in. So you're in sort of a grey zone there, meaning that's, you know, you, you don't know what laws are being enforced. You essentially have to look at each guideline and that can go through each individual university processes, university guidelines, how they run it and there's variations and how they enforce it is different. And I would argue, and some of my colleagues would argue quite strongly that that's that's inherently unfair and they make whatever decision they want. And if there's a personal problem with that particular
处于那个虚无地带。你真的不知道你会处理什么，那不是正确的词。我喜欢，我喜欢虚无地带。让我们保留它。所以你处于某种灰色地带，意味着（你知道，你不知道什么法律正在被执行）。你基本上必须查看每一项指导方针，这可以通过每个单独的大学程序、大学指导方针、他们如何运行它，并且在他们如何执行它方面存在差异。我会争辩，我的一些同事会非常强烈地争辩说，这本质上是不公平的，他们做出他们想要的任何决定。如果对那个特定的……
trainee, then that's going to override anything else. And if that straight trainee, for example, has needed extra supervision for whatever reason and it's caused a bit of a disruptance, disruptions in the course and there may be yeah a lot of people unhappy with that person's behavior but it doesn't necessarily mean they're not going to be a great psychologist that personal that personal relationship can't be overlooked so when the for example a trainee may be at a final hearing uh FTP final hearing at university FTP proceedings and the main evidence is being presented by a supervisor now we this may be very evident a very qualified eminent fantastic at her job his job whoever it may be but
实习生有个人问题，那么这将凌驾于其他一切之上。如果那个实习生，例如，因为某种原因需要额外的督导，并且导致了一点混乱，课程中的中断，并且可能（是的）很多人对那个人的行为不满意，但这并不一定意味着他们不会成为一名伟大的心理学家。那种个人关系不能被忽视。所以当，例如，一名实习生可能在大学FTP程序的最终听证会上，FTP最终听证会，而主要证据是由一名督导提出的。现在我们，这可能非常明显，一个非常有资格、杰出、工作出色的人，无论他是谁，无论她是谁，但……
But if there's a personal issue with there, then that is going to influence how the panel view that. And that's something that does not happen at the HCPC regulatory proceedings or in a higher proceedings. So I think it's something that could be addressed either through associations like the ACP UK or various representative bodies, about how can we manage this better?
如果那里有个人问题，那么这将影响小组委员会如何看待这一点。这是在HCPC监管程序或更高级别的程序中不会发生的事情。所以我认为这是可以通过像ACP UK这样的协会或各种代表机构来解决的事情，关于我们如何能更好地管理这一点？
Because to me, it feels unfair and it's disproportionately affecting those of different ethnic backgrounds, of who have new, neurodivergence who may not conform to what we see society's norms. So it's something that I think should be looked into. Yeah, I think another issue that I kind of struggled to get my head around is the fact that for people that are not self-funding, their employer will be the NHS, certainly for
因为对我来说，这感觉不公平，而且它不成比例地影响了那些不同种族背景的人，那些有神经多样性的人，他们可能不符合我们所看到的社会规范。所以我认为这是应该调查的事情。是的，我认为我有点难以理解的另一个问题是，对于那些不是自费的人，他们的雇主将是NHS，当然对于……
training clinical psychologists anyway. But it might well be that the procedures are being raised by a university. And I presume, it's been too long, I can't remember, I don't know if I signed some stuff to say that I would be a good girl when I was training with my university as well as my employer, or whether I only signed a contract with my NHS. I feel like I only did that. But it might have changed more recently. But then you're in a position where the university are not your employer and yet are obviously holding you to account. And then you might be in a position where you don't really have much control because of the power different, especially if maybe you're, like you said, if you're, you and your supervisors just don't get along.
培训临床心理学家来说是这样。但很可能是程序是由大学提出的。我推测（时间太长了，我不记得了，我不知道我是否签署了一些东西说我会在与大学以及雇主培训时做一个好女孩，或者我是否只与我的NHS签署了合同。我觉得我只做了那个）。但它最近可能发生了变化。但随后你处于一个大学不是你的雇主，但显然在让你负责的位置。然后你可能处于一个因为权力差异而没有太多控制权的位置，特别是如果可能你是，就像你说的，如果你和你的督导就是合不来。
And like, you know, if you met each other a hundred times across different years, you still would hate each other. Like it's just a personality mismatch. And then there really is inequity. Absolutely. 100% agree. Absolutely. I mean, that's sort of conflict between employer and university, particularly in the final years,
就像，你知道，如果你在不同的年份见过一百次，你仍然会讨厌对方。就像这只是性格不合。然后真的存在不平等。绝对。100%同意。绝对。我的意思是，雇主和大学之间的那种冲突，特别是在最后几年，
the final months of training. which is across all professions, but it's quite volatile in my experience with psychology, particularly clinical psychologists, because you know, you're on the cold face, you're dealing with vulnerable people, and also your employer is, they're trying to run an organisation. So the fact that you're in your final year of training, there is an understanding, hey, wait a second, this person is learning, but in the eyes of an underfunded NHS trust or in a particular department, they need this person to do their job properly, that they're relying on them to have that particular the caseload 510 whatever the caseload may be and the student may not be ready for that so the
培训的最后几个月。这在所有专业中都存在，但在我与心理学（特别是临床心理学家）的经验中，它是相当不稳定的，因为你知道，你在前线，你在处理弱势群体，而且你的雇主是，他们试图经营一个组织。所以你处于培训的最后一年这一事实，有一种理解，嘿，等一下，这个人正在学习，但在资金不足的NHS信托或特定部门的眼中，他们需要这个人正确地完成他们的工作，他们依赖他们拥有那个特定的病例量（5、10，无论病例量是多少），而学生可能还没有准备好，所以……
academic requirements from the university are too great um considering that the employer is actually asking yeah well you're running a caseload now and the university and they're expecting a certain standard and what i would argue and what i do argue in final hearings regularly and in our submissions and in our appealed is that this person is still learning um and so you know they're not the finished product yet they're not the finished professional and then i think feel like the conflict between the placement and the necessity to use their hands, their man hours, the fact that they're needed on the ground because of underfunding, I would argue, and I'm sure that a lot of your listeners would agree with that. They're asked to do too much too soon, and that
大学的学术要求太高了，考虑到雇主实际上在问“是的，你现在正在处理病例量”，而大学，他们期望一个特定的标准。我所争辩的，以及我在最终听证会、我们的陈述和我们的上诉中经常争辩的是，这个人还在学习，所以（你知道）他们还不是成品，他们还不是成熟的专业人员。然后我觉得实习和使用他们的手、他们的人工时数、他们因为资金不足而在地面上被需要的事实之间的冲突，我会争辩（我相信你的很多听众会同意这一点）。他们被要求做得太多、太快，而那……
leaves them open to, first of all, burnout, which is obviously a very common thing. In my experience, I've seen people just quit the profession. I really have seen that happen. And also, you know the expectations of maintaining this standard they've never met before because I've never done it before and in other professions I give the example of a radiologist who I work with in their final year in their placement you know if they're taking a scan for example and determining whether this thing is you know what's the type of growth it is or for example whether it's whether it's a tear or whether it's a break now that's probably going to be looked at by someone else briefly because it's not just a client-facing direct role I imagine there's
让他们容易受到，首先是倦怠，这显然是一件非常普遍的事情。根据我的经验，我见过人们直接退出这个行业。我真的见过这种情况发生。而且，你知道，维持这个他们从未达到过的标准的期望，因为我以前从未做过。在其他专业中，我举一个我合作过的放射科医生的例子，在他们实习的最后一年，你知道，如果他们正在进行扫描，例如，并确定这个东西是什么（你知道，它是什么类型的生长物），或者例如它是撕裂还是骨折。现在那可能很快会被其他人看一眼，因为它不仅仅是一个面向客户的直接角色，我想有……
there's an extra layer of supervision. But if you are alone, your supervisor can't sit in on your one-on-one session. So it's a different type of, you know, it's real and it happens immediately. So there's no means of sort of supervising that aspect of it. And that can very quickly lead to conflict between both, between the university and the employer. Essentially, the employer going, well, I've got to raise this complaint because, look, you haven't done your job properly. I've got to tell your university because they're asking how you're going and I'm running the report. And then all of a sudden you're in the process. And it's hard to get out of because once you're on that FTP track.
额外的督导层。但如果你是一个人，你的督导不能坐在你的一对一会议中。所以这是不同类型的，你知道，它是真实的，并且立即发生。所以没有办法监督它的那个方面。这很快会导致两者之间的冲突，在大学和雇主之间。本质上，雇主说，好吧，我必须提出这个投诉，因为，看，你没有正确地完成你的工作。我必须告诉你的大学，因为他们正在问你做得怎么样，而我正在运行报告。然后突然之间你就进入了程序。而且很难摆脱，因为一旦你进入了那个FTP轨道。
And again, if you don't want to scare people, trainees and students, the majority of people will never encounter any FTP proceedings university. I mean, it's, but it does happen. And when it does happen, my advice would be from the outset is, you know, the university present this initial informal chat as not being part of an FTP process, because it's not really. But things that happen in that first informal meeting will dictate which track it goes on. Once you're in that FTP process and the formal investigation is undertaken, yeah, the advice is to try and get some help, whether it's through your student representatives or through legal advice or some people who understand this process.
同样，如果你不想吓唬人，实习生和学生，大多数人永远不会遇到任何大学FTP程序。我的意思是，它是，但它确实发生了。当它确实发生时，我的建议是从一开始就是，你知道，大学将这种最初的非正式聊天呈现为不是FTP程序的一部分，因为它确实不是。但在那第一次非正式会议中发生的事情将决定它进入哪个轨道。一旦你进入了那个FTP程序，并且进行了正式调查，是的，建议是尝试寻求一些帮助，无论是通过你的学生代表还是通过法律建议，或者一些了解这个过程的人。
And I think that in certain circumstances, my colleagues will agree with me here. There's a did that universities can be somewhat disingenuous by saying this is not adversarial, we're trying to help you. but the repercussions and the sanctions that they can impose are severe and can really affect your future ability to practice. So to try and exclude legal representation from the very stages of the process, which they actively do. They say, no, I don't think you should bring someone. Some laws actually say within the university you can't bring someone is problematic. And that's something I think the ACP should look into and various other organisations as well. Yeah, thank you for that.
而且我认为在某些情况下，我的同事会在这里同意我的观点。大学通过说“这不是对抗性的，我们正在试图帮助你”来表现得有点虚伪，但他们可以施加的后果和制裁是严重的，并且真的会影响你未来的执业能力。所以试图在程序的最初阶段排除法律代表（他们积极这样做），他们说“不，我不认为你应该带人来”。有些法律实际上说在大学内你不能带人来，这是有问题的。我认为ACP以及其他各种组织也应该调查这一点。是的，谢谢你。
I thought what we'd do is we'd go on to a little quickfire round. Absolutely. see how we get on with that. Okay, so with the fitness to practice for trainees, is it possible that it goes to stage one, you put some kind of procedures in place to change things, and then it never goes any further and it's just resolved and done? Absolutely. And I'd argue that's the most common way that these things resolve themselves. So the stage one issues may be in terms of lateness, maybe in terms of social media, slightly inappropriate communication, they're resolved.
我想我们接下来进行一个快速问答环节。当然可以。看看我们进行得如何。好的，关于实习生的执业能力问题，是否可能进入第一阶段，你采取了一些程序来改变现状，然后事情就此结束，问题得到解决？当然可以。而且我认为这是此类问题最常见的解决方式。所以第一阶段的问题可能涉及迟到、社交媒体使用或稍微不当的沟通，这些问题都得到了解决。
you'll apologise, you write the appropriate letter, you show demonstrative learning, and then it finishes. So yeah, absolutely. That's the aim and the objective of the university at that stage. Thank you. Next question. With social media, is it true that even as pre-qualified staff, we need to be really careful about what we're putting out there into the world? Absolutely. I mean, I would argue that it's almost on a part because, and obviously, obviously with younger trainees, they will be more versed in how this, in this world, it's literally part of society now, much more than when I was at university. But in terms of data protection, in terms of identification issues, well, obviously you won't necessarily, hopefully you won't
你会道歉，写一封合适的信，展示出你已经吸取了教训，然后事情就结束了。所以是的，绝对是这样。这就是大学在那个阶段的目标和目的。谢谢。下一个问题。关于社交媒体，作为预注册员工，我们是否真的需要非常小心我们在世界上发布的内容？当然。我的意思是，我认为这几乎是同等重要的，因为，显然，对于年轻的实习生来说，他们会更精通这个世界，这现在确实是社会的一部分，比我上大学时要多得多。但在数据保护方面，在身份识别问题方面，好吧，显然你不一定会，希望你不会
identify a client, your other colleagues, group photos, in terms of whether other people have have agreed to be involved in this particular chat, you know, being, you know, very wary also of your opinions. If you're going to be focal about a particular political opinion, whatever that may be, make sure that it's, that it's, first of all, adheres to the standards of your particular traineeship, so whatever the NHS may be, whatever hospital you're working, whatever you're doing, private practice, whatever it may be. Yeah, just be very wary and just stay clear of at this stage on the public account of making you know we don't want people to be robots not have political opinions but yeah just be careful privacy data protection and also yeah some of the comments that you
识别出客户、你的其他同事、集体照片，关于其他人是否同意参与这个特定的聊天，你知道，也要非常警惕你的观点。如果你要对某个特定的政治观点发表看法，无论那是什么，确保它首先符合你特定实习项目的标准，所以无论NHS是什么，无论你在哪家医院工作，无论你在做什么，私人执业，无论它是什么。是的，只需非常警惕，在这个阶段在公共账户上保持清醒，我们不希望人们成为机器人，没有政治观点，但是的，只需小心隐私、数据保护，还有，是的，你所做的一些评论
know you make can if someone picks it up maybe it's someone else in you that you have there's a personal issue with or someone it doesn't necessarily have to be your university that has actually picked out hey that comment was inappropriate maybe someone else you don't even know they can raise that complaint to the university so that applies to pre-register registered it's it's really a a major source of FTP complaints for the HCPC and also for universities. Thank you. Would it be enough to add to your social media bio? Views are my own, not my employers. Is that enough to cover a trainee or someone who's not yet qualified or even someone who's qualified for that matter? Is it enough? No, does it help potentially? Yes. I mean it is a
你知道，如果你发表了评论，如果有人发现了它，也许是你在工作中与之有个人问题的人，或者其他人，不一定非要是你的大学发现了，嘿，那个评论是不合适的，也许是其他你甚至不认识的人，他们可以向大学提出投诉，所以这适用于预注册和已注册人员，这确实是HCPC和大学FTP投诉的主要来源。谢谢。在你的社交媒体简介中加上“观点仅代表个人，不代表雇主”是否足够？这足以涵盖实习生或尚未获得资格的人，甚至是有资格的人吗？这足够吗？不，它有帮助吗？可能吧。我的意思是它是一个
disclaimer that legally doesn't really count for anything. Obviously if your work, it depends on not the type of work you're doing, but I think, I think we all know the answer is essentially that's not going to prevent a complaint being made if what you're saying is completely unreasonable and irresponsible. So no, within reason, if it's a nuanced idea about, say for example, you may be critical of the NHS and how they're operating certain procedures, yeah, potentially that's not going to be a problem. You're saying this is not what my employee says, but if it's a strong view either way, political, social, then yeah, that's not, that's not going to save you from any sort of FDP process. I was raised in a way that kind of told
免责声明，在法律上并没有什么实际意义。显然，如果你的工作，这取决于你所做工作的类型，但我认为，我们都知道答案本质上是，如果你的言论完全不合理和不负责任，那并不能阻止投诉的发生。所以不，在合理范围内，如果这是一个关于，比如说，你可能对NHS及其运作某些程序的方式持批评态度，是的，这可能不会成为问题。你说这不是我雇主说的，但如果这是一个强烈的观点，无论是政治上的还是社会上的，那么是的，那不会，那不会让你免于任何形式的FTP程序。我成长的过程中，有人告诉我
me, never slate your employer on internal emails, never say that you wish you didn't work there, never criticise your employer publicly because otherwise that can be used against you, and that's something I've definitely held on to. I mean, whether it's a wise career choice is, is a different issue, whether you slagging off the head of the hospital, but whether they're two separate issues, you may lose your job and you may be asked to find separate employment, but that's not necessarily going to be an FTP issue. Does it go to your competency? Does it go to your learning? I'd argue not, depending obviously what they said. But yeah, you probably get sacked, but you won't have any problems with FTP. Okay, thank you. Is it true that some universities
永远不要在内部邮件中抨击你的雇主，永远不要说你希望你没有在那里工作，永远不要公开批评你的雇主，因为否则这可能会被用来对付你，这是我绝对坚持的一点。我的意思是，这是否是一个明智的职业选择是另一个问题，无论你是否在背后诋毁医院院长，但它们是两个独立的问题，你可能会失去工作，你可能会被要求寻找其他工作，但这不一定会成为FTP问题。这是否涉及你的能力？这是否涉及你的学习？我认为不会，当然取决于他们说了什么。但是的，你可能会被解雇，但你不会有任何FTP方面的问题。好的，谢谢。有些大学是否真的
have a very low tolerance for failed academic assignments and that even as few as two or three failed academic assignments can lead to fitness to practice that ultimately leads to you not finishing your course. I mean in my experience no that's not necessarily the the case in my experience the types of matters as they relate to clinical practice and proficiency will need to be broad wide ranging and serious so obviously depends on depending how important those particular academic tasks were, if that were your major component, and you've tried it again and then again and again.
对不及格的学术作业容忍度很低，甚至仅仅两三次不及格的学术作业就可能导致执业能力问题，最终导致你无法完成课程？我的经验是，不，这不一定是那样。在我的经验中，与临床实践和熟练程度相关的问题需要是广泛的、全面的和严重的，所以显然取决于那些特定的学术任务有多重要，如果那是你的主要组成部分，而你已经尝试了一次又一次。
But generally, the university FTP processes, and then eventually the HCP, they're not there to try and punish individual mistakes. That's really not the purpose of the whole process. And I'd argue at university stage, it's absolutely not the purpose. So I have no students who are now clients or trainees who are now clients,
但总的来说，大学的FTP程序，以及最终的HCPC，它们并不是为了惩罚个人的错误。这真的不是整个过程的目的。而且我认为在大学阶段，这绝对不是目的。所以我没有学生现在是客户或实习生现在是客户，
where they've failed, or two things. It's generally a broad pattern of behaviour, serious misconduct, dishonesty, these types of matters, major communication issues. The ones that go to the end and you end up being excluded from the course, which is one of the options opening. And if you get excluded from a course, it's very difficult to find another placement in a different university. It's not impossible, but in my experience, it can lead to at least a very long gap in your ability to become a professional but overall it really is it's the serious matters to do with this honesty repeated failings um for example note taking one example that i can think of is repeated issues
他们失败了，或者两件事。这通常是一种广泛的行为模式、严重的不当行为、不诚实，这些类型的问题，重大的沟通问题。那些走到最后并最终被排除在课程之外的人，这是开放的选项之一。如果你被排除在课程之外，很难在另一所大学找到另一个实习机会。这并非不可能，但在我的经验中，这可能导致你成为专业人士的能力出现至少很长的空白，但总的来说，这确实是与不诚实、重复失败有关的严重问题，例如笔记记录，我能想到的一个例子是重复出现的问题
in terms of not in insufficient notes but in complete notes or no notes whatsoever so for example a student a trainee in their last couple of of may have five or six uh students my five or six clients they're very hectic they've got academic work going on they've got work at home they're stressed they're not sleeping enough they meet a vulnerable teenager in this circumstances they meet a vulnerable teenager that he says some very important information that needs to be passed on to the next um psychologists who will see him as it may not necessarily be that that front-facing psychologist and there's no no there's no note at all and this if this happened once maybe that can be rectified. If this happens again and again and again, this becomes a public safety issue.
在笔记方面，不是笔记不足，而是不完整的笔记或根本没有笔记，所以例如，一个处于最后阶段的实习生可能有五六个客户，他们非常忙碌，他们有学术工作要做，他们有家庭工作，他们压力很大，他们睡眠不足，在这种情况下，他们遇到了一位脆弱的青少年，他说了一些非常重要的信息，需要传达给下一位将要见到他的心理学家，这可能不一定是那位面对面的心理学家，而且根本没有任何笔记，如果这种情况发生了一次，也许可以纠正。如果这种情况一次又一次地发生，这就成了公共安全问题。
I think we can all understand that. Well, wait a second, this person was in a very vulnerable state, and that note could have potentially prevented a major catastrophe or, you know, endangered life. So I do understand why they do this, but overall two or three mistakes are not going to cost you your ability to be registered and shouldn't really lead you to the FTP track. That would be my answer to that. Thank you. So with the rise of AI supported note taking, do you think that will lead to less fitness to practice issues or do you think that could potentially cover up the disclosure of other fitness to practice issues? Yeah, very interesting question. And it's, it's, I fear that, I, I envision that that's going to be an avalanche of future cases and how that, you know, how AI is managed within
我想我们都能理解这一点。好吧，等一下，这个人处于非常脆弱的状态，那份笔记可能本可以防止一场重大灾难，或者，你知道，危及生命。所以我确实理解他们为什么这样做，但总的来说，两三次错误不会让你失去注册资格，也不应该真的让你进入FTP轨道。这就是我的回答。谢谢。那么随着人工智能辅助笔记的兴起，你认为这会导致更少的执业能力问题，还是你认为这可能会掩盖其他执业能力问题的披露？是的，非常有趣的问题。而且，我担心，我预见到这将是未来案件的雪崩，以及人工智能在
clinical settings is going to be something that is going to be yeah going to be a lot of my work and really lead to a lot of fdp cases at the moment the issues in relation to that i can see in relation to a i know taking really if it's a accepted um a recognized and safety proof a i system that's being used and is and is being supported by whatever institution is and you using it appropriately then i think it's actually a real asset and a real help and what i can see is people who had time management issues and I have clients who wish and they've said to me they wish these systems were in place before they had their problems because a lot of the issues was purely time management. So do I think there's there's going to be an improvement in terms
临床环境中的管理方式将是，是的，将是我大量工作的内容，并真正导致大量的FTP案件。目前，我能看到的与人工智能笔记相关的问题，如果它是一个被接受的、公认的和安全证明的人工智能系统，并且正在被任何机构使用，并且你正在适当地使用它，那么我认为它实际上是一个真正的资产和真正的帮助。我所看到的是那些有时间管理问题的人，我有客户希望，他们曾对我说，他们希望在他们遇到问题之前就有这些系统，因为很多问题纯粹是时间管理。所以我认为会有所改善吗？
of FTP issues? I think it could work two ways. Some people who time management was the issue. It's going to definitely help them. They won't fall of the FTP matters. In terms of AI generating false notes, I mean, how we actually, how we determine that, that could be some dishonesty issue. And if we find out retrospectively that these notes are actually not an accurate reflection of the meeting, then you go into dishonesty. And any dishonesty across the board anywhere, and that's where I think AI can be a problem as it may lead to some dishonest submissions. It may be some dishonest note taking or some, then that becomes a problem.
关于FTP问题？我认为它可能以两种方式起作用。对于那些时间管理是问题的人来说。它肯定会帮助他们。他们不会陷入FTP问题。关于人工智能生成虚假笔记，我的意思是，我们实际上如何确定这一点，这可能是一个不诚实的问题。如果我们事后发现这些笔记实际上不是会议的准确反映，那么你就进入了不诚实的问题。任何地方的任何不诚实行为，这就是我认为人工智能可能成为问题的地方，因为它可能导致一些不诚实的提交。它可能是一些不诚实的笔记记录，或者其他什么，那么这就成了问题。
Dishonesty is frowned upon as we understand. And the punishment is, yeah, severe sanctions in relation to dishonesty. So it's going to be a space we're definitely going to need to watch, both as clinicians and also as legal advisors. It's interesting. We're not sure where it's going yet. Thank you. Next question. Can a trainee refuse to engage in fitness to practice proceedings? I mean, absolutely they can. Everyone has the right to do whatever they wish to do. That's also the case at once registered. If you don't want to engage in any process, there's no legal obligation for you to do so outside of a criminal. investigation. However, if you do decide to remove yourself disengaged and not have any contact with the university and later wrong with the HCPC, it's really going to be frowned upon. And I guess what that goes to is what we discussed earlier, this idea of insight. So if you don't
正如我们所理解的，不诚实是不被赞成的。惩罚是，是的，与不诚实相关的严厉制裁。所以这将是一个我们绝对需要关注的空间，无论是作为临床医生还是作为法律顾问。这很有趣。我们还不确定它会走向何方。谢谢。下一个问题。实习生可以拒绝参与执业能力程序吗？我的意思是，他们当然可以。每个人都有权做他们想做的事。一旦注册，情况也是如此。如果你不想参与任何程序，除了刑事调查外，你没有法律义务这样做。然而，如果你决定让自己脱离，不参与，并且与大学没有任何联系，后来又与HCPC没有任何联系，这真的会受到不赞成。我想这涉及到我们之前讨论过的，关于洞察力的想法。所以如果你不
think you did anything wrong, and it may be the case, and the facts may come to prove that later on, but you just say, look, this is unfair, I'm not engaging with it, I didn't do that. And the process starts, level one, tier one, however you want to view it, and then potentially you don't turn up. I don't want to go there. I don't agree. You guys can all go do whatever you want. Then eventually they're going to make, they're going to have a finding without you there. And then they're going to potentially lead to a full FDB investigation. You still don't engage, as is you're right. You are likely to be either suspended from the course if you, depending on the seriousness of the matters. But what I suggest, all clients post, post registration, pre-registation,
认为你做错了什么，事实可能在以后证明确实如此，但你只是说，看，这不公平，我不参与，我没做过。然后程序开始了，第一级，第一层，无论你怎么看，然后你可能没有出现。我不想去那里。我不同意。你们都可以做你们想做的。然后最终他们会做出，他们会在你不在场的情况下做出裁决。然后他们将可能导致全面的FTP调查。你仍然不参与，这是你的权利。你很可能会被停课，如果你，取决于问题的严重性。但我建议，所有客户在注册后，注册前，
actively engage. Actively engage. You can disagree. You can absolutely disagree. And that's where have your viewpoint heard, but a lack of engagement shows a lack of respect to the university, to the institution, to clients, again, depending on the issue, but I think it's legally not otherwise move and I would not suggest you can disagree and get some support in how you respond, but yeah, if someone's raised a complaint, they need to have it heard properly. Thank you. This might well be the last of our quickfire round questions, but if someone is struggling personally and they're recognising that because they've got some insight, is it better for them to just self-disclose that or to wait for proceedings to maybe be started against them
积极参与。积极参与。你可以不同意。你绝对可以不同意。这就是你的观点被听取的地方，但缺乏参与表现出对大学、对机构、对客户缺乏尊重，同样，取决于问题，但我认为这在法律上不是其他举动，我不建议你不同意并获得一些关于如何回应的支持，但是的，如果有人提出了投诉，他们需要得到妥善的听取。谢谢。这很可能是我们快速问答环节的最后一个问题，但如果有人个人正在挣扎，并且他们因为有洞察力而意识到了这一点，他们最好是自己披露这一点，还是等待程序可能针对他们开始
by someone else? I mean, I think it's a common occurrence in relation to health. And health can be in terms of how you're managing your caseload, how you're managing your studies. It doesn't have to be actual physical ailments. It can be anxiety. It can be sleep. It can be whatever's happening in your personal life if you feel like you can't meet the requirements of the course, which happens to many people across various sectors across all sorts of higher level education. My advice would be really nip it in the butt early, get there early. And you know, it doesn't necessarily have to be a the installment of reasonable adjustments, which is something universities can offer, which I actually not as difficult to have put in place as as one piece that people may think.
由其他人发起？我的意思是，我认为这在健康方面是一个普遍现象。健康可以指你如何管理你的病例，你如何管理你的学习。它不一定非要是实际的身体疾病。它可以是焦虑。它可以是睡眠。它可以是你的个人生活中发生的任何事情，如果你觉得你无法满足课程的要求，这发生在各个部门、各种高等教育中的许多人身上。我的建议是尽早解决它，尽早处理。你知道，这不一定非要是合理的调整，这是大学可以提供的东西，这实际上并不像人们可能认为的那样难以实施。
So, you know, essentially reasonable adjustments are something that they're there to help university students but if you are struggling psychologically if you have if you have for example an undisclosed or or unknown mental health issue or neurodivergence or something else in your life of death of death of family member a lot of people say well that's my business i don't want to get involved but if that's going to have a noticeable impact on your on your ability to complete the coursework or particularly during the final stages of your placement absolutely reach out and that can be reaching out to various people within the university there's obviously there's a lot of support systems within there, reaching out first and foremost to your supervisor, letting them know,
所以，你知道，本质上合理的调整是帮助大学生的东西，但如果你在心理上挣扎，如果你有，例如，一个未披露的或未知的心理健康问题或神经多样性，或者你生活中其他的事情，家庭成员的死亡，很多人说，好吧，那是我的事，我不想参与，但如果这对你完成课程的能力有明显的影响，或者特别是在你实习的最后阶段，绝对要寻求帮助，这可以联系大学里的各种人，显然那里有很多支持系统，首先要联系你的导师，让他们知道，
can I take, can I get extra time off? There's a lot of things that can happen before it escalates, because once that escalation happens, and I've seen it, you know, particularly with burnout, mental health issues, once that, once that we've reached that stage, it becomes like a deck of cards. Things start falling down very, very quickly and I've noticed something that had been addressed very early in proceedings in terms of, you know, an unmanned, managed health condition can had they had they reached out at that stage we could have potentially stopped everything that came went henceforth because actually all of this could have been done could have been done appropriately with proper support
我可以请假吗？在事态升级之前，有很多事情可以发生，因为一旦升级发生，我见过，你知道，特别是在倦怠、心理健康问题方面，一旦我们达到了那个阶段，它就像纸牌屋一样。事情开始非常非常快地倒塌，我注意到一些在程序早期就得到解决的事情，就，你知道，一个未管理的健康状况，如果他们在那个阶段寻求帮助，我们本可以阻止此后发生的一切，因为实际上所有这些本可以适当地完成，并得到适当的支持
and universities are essentially supportive places supportive institutions that's the experience I had that's the experience most people have but if you don't tell people struggling then it could look like that actually I'm just not up to scratch actually I don't care and you know I strongly advise yeah people to reach out as soon as it becomes as soon as it has a visible effect on their work. You don't have to, if you're managing, fine, but as soon as it actually visibly affects your ability to practice
大学本质上是支持性的地方，支持性的机构，这是我的经验，这是大多数人的经验，但如果你不告诉人们你在挣扎，那么这看起来可能就像，实际上我只是不够格，实际上我不在乎，你知道，我强烈建议人们在它对他们的工作产生可见影响时尽快寻求帮助。你不必，如果你能应付，没问题，但一旦它实际上明显影响了你的执业能力
or to complete work, then yeah, reach out immediately. Yeah, I think we can get in our own heads as well, can't we be thinking like, well, I started with my cohort. I really want to graduate with them and be able to all celebrate together. But actually, we're all on our own journey. And if you need to take some paid sick leave out from the course to really get yourself well, I would always advocate for that. Look after yourself first and know that actually, you know,
或完成工作的能力，那么是的，立即寻求帮助。是的，我认为我们也可以陷入自己的思维中，不是吗？想着，好吧，我和我的同伴一起开始。我真的很想和他们一起毕业，并且能够一起庆祝。但实际上，我们都在自己的旅程上。如果你需要从课程中休一些带薪病假来真正让自己好起来，我总是会提倡这样做。首先照顾好自己，并知道实际上，你知道，
the people that you've started training with might still come and celebrate you outside your graduation ceremony on the day that you graduate because they're not going to forget that you exist. You're still part of that. And actually you being happy, healthy, well and thriving in your training is what everybody wants for you. Absolutely. I mean, from my experience, everyone has their different, their own their own path through studies, particularly in a stressful job like psychology,
你开始培训的人可能仍然会在你毕业那天在毕业典礼外来庆祝你，因为他们不会忘记你的存在。你仍然是其中的一部分。而且实际上你快乐、健康、良好并在你的培训中茁壮成长是每个人对你的期望。当然。我的意思是，根据我的经验，每个人在学习过程中都有自己不同的道路，特别是在像心理学这样压力大的工作中，
you know, looking after yourself is fundamental, also for your ability to safely look after other people. It's a different job, it's a different calling if you want. So yeah, absolutely. People get there when they get there and if you go, what doesn't want to support you, when you eventually get there, maybe they weren't really the people you wanted to hang out with, hang out with anyway. Such great advice, Nicholas. All right, so before we say goodbye, at least for now, can you let us know if someone is, you know, at the beginning of this or kind of aware of someone else in their team who's going through this, what advice would you have for them? Yeah, I guess it's a question I get asked retrospectively from, from, from, from,
你知道，照顾好自己是根本，对于你安全地照顾其他人的能力也是如此。这是一份不同的工作，如果你愿意的话，这是一个不同的使命。所以是的，当然。人们在他们到达的时候到达，如果你去，不想支持你，当你最终到达那里时，也许他们真的不是你想与之交往的人。非常好的建议，尼古拉斯。好的，所以在我们说再见之前，至少现在是这样，你能告诉我们如果有人，你知道，处于这个阶段的开始，或者意识到他们团队中的其他人正在经历这个，你会有什么建议给他们？是的，我想这是一个我事后被问到的问题，从，从，从，从，
from trainees and also from employees, what could we have done differently? I guess my answer would be when the concern is originally raised and you now have joined the process, so essentially you're now in the proceedings. There may be an informal meeting, as we discussed, that informal meeting is informal, but you're essentially on the pathway towards a formal FTP hearing.
从实习生和员工那里，我们本可以做些什么不同的事情？我想我的回答是，当最初提出担忧时，你现在已经加入了这个过程，所以本质上你现在处于程序中。可能会有一个非正式的会议，正如我们讨论的那样，那个非正式会议是非正式的，但你本质上是在通往正式FTP听证会的道路上。
I would at the very least reach out to student services, student representatives, student bodies to say, hey, wait a second, is this something I need to treat seriously? because what I find with trainees and with students at the beginning and trainees at the end is that there's a complete lack of understanding of this FTP process. And I understand it. I understand that people have never encountered this before. It's an abstract concept, current impairment.
我至少会联系学生服务处、学生代表、学生团体，说，嘿，等一下，这是我需要认真对待的事情吗？因为我在开始时的实习生和学生以及结束时的实习生身上发现的是，对这个FTP过程完全缺乏了解。我理解它。我理解人们以前从未遇到过这种情况。这是一个抽象的概念，当前的损害。
What does this actually mean? So you can have these sort of small complaint that had to do with an email you sent what you wore, social media posts, some data protection, an essay that you submitted that they have their doubts about, and it may be quite minor. And maybe that first stage is just a very small stage. But even if you think it's not that important, actually, there's nothing to it, I'd reach out to someone who has a bit more experience. Now, whether that's a practitioner or a legal advisor or someone within the university, at least, particularly at that first stage, so they can give you some perspective of what realm we're in, how serious is this?
这到底意味着什么？所以你可以有这种小的投诉，与你发送的电子邮件、你的穿着、社交媒体帖子、一些数据保护、你提交的一篇论文有关，他们对此有疑问，这可能相当小。也许第一阶段只是一个非常小的阶段。但即使你认为它没那么重要，实际上，没什么大不了的，我会联系一个更有经验的人。现在，无论是从业者还是法律顾问，还是大学里的人，至少，特别是在第一阶段，这样他们可以给你一些关于我们处于什么领域的视角，这有多严重？
I'd definitely have a discussion with those that you're working with closely. If you're at the end of your training obviously depends who raise the complaint but if if you're supervisor who's you know actively with you on a daily basis and it's unrelated to that supervisor hey having a chat to them if you're at that stage of the proceedings and and from that point onwards if it does decide to go into a formal investigation and and or for example the student representative body or the student support service said hey this is pretty serious I think you should get some advice before that first hearing the tier one hearing then reach out to a
我肯定会与你密切合作的人进行讨论。如果你在培训结束时，显然取决于谁提出了投诉，但如果你的导师，你知道，每天都和你在一起，并且与那个导师无关，嘿，和他们聊聊，如果你处于程序的那个阶段，从那时起，如果它确实决定进入正式调查，并且，例如，学生代表机构或学生支持服务说，嘿，这相当严重，我认为你应该在第一次听证会，即第一层听证会之前获得一些建议，那么联系一个
If you get told or you have the feeling that actually wait a second, this has to do with dishonesty, this has to do with something that they're taking very seriously. And the fact that they've raised a complaint and they've called a hearing suggests there's something to it. They're not just raising a complaint because you said the, you know, one inappropriate thing or you were late repeatedly. That can be done informally. That can be done with a chat. Hey, supervisor coming in. You're turning up late.
如果你被告知或者你有这种感觉，实际上等一下，这与不诚实有关，这与他们非常认真对待的事情有关。他们提出了投诉并召开了听证会这一事实表明其中有一定道理。他们不仅仅是因为你说了，你知道，一件不恰当的事情或者你反复迟到而提出投诉。这可以非正式地完成。这可以通过聊天完成。嘿，导师进来了。你迟到了。
You need to pick up your game. If it's reached that stage one, definitely reach out. I have clients who reach out to me at stage one. So we're always open to that. But the student bodies are definitely worth discussing. And once the decision has been made at stage one, that there's a formal investigation, I'd absolutely seek out professional advice.
你需要提高你的表现。如果它达到了第一阶段，一定要联系。我有客户在第一阶段联系我。所以我们总是对此持开放态度。但学生团体绝对值得讨论。一旦在第一阶段做出了决定，即有正式调查，我绝对会寻求专业建议。
Again, who that's with is entirely up to you, but someone who has a rigorous understanding of the university guidelines and the fact that the FTP processes are different depending on which university you're in. So yeah, reach out particularly post-stage one, but if you can make some inquiries in terms of pre-stage one. Because once you're on that track, even if the university call it informal, there's notes from that. And there's eventually going to be leading you towards, hopefully not, but can potentially be leading you towards a full FTP university hearing. Thank you so much.
同样，那是和谁一起完全取决于你，但要找一个对大学指导方针有严格理解的人，并且FTP程序根据你所在的大学而有所不同。所以是的，特别是在第一阶段之后联系，但如果你能在第一阶段之前进行一些咨询。因为一旦你走上那条轨道，即使大学称之为非正式，也有关于它的笔记。并且最终将引导你走向，希望不会，但可能潜在地引导你走向全面的FTP大学听证会。非常感谢。
And with that in mind, could you please let our listeners and our viewers know where people can find out more about you and your work? Yeah, absolutely. If people want to reach out, even for some informal advice or just to have a chat in relation to these issues or any other issues, I can be found on LinkedIn, which really probably the best place to find me and show some of the services they offer and some of the work that I do. And that's Nicholas Stockling, St-O-C-K-L-I-N-G. And you can find me on LinkedIn. And I'll be more than happy to help. Perfect. Thank you so much. And I'll link LinkedIn in the show notes and in the description with the video. Thank you so much for your time and for the work that you do in supporting people in a really vulnerable time of their lives, Nicholas. Thank you very much. It's been a really interesting discussion. I think it's something that hopefully was helpful for various people, the various stages of their professional training. Absolutely will be. Thank you again for your time. All the best. You too. Thank you so much again to my guest, Nicholas Sturkling. Please do go and check him out on LinkedIn. He really is a safe port in the storm if you are struggling with fitness.
考虑到这一点，你能请我们的听众和观众告诉人们在哪里可以找到更多关于你和你工作的信息吗？是的，当然。如果人们想联系，即使是为了获得一些非正式的建议，或者只是为了就这些问题或任何其他问题进行聊天，可以在LinkedIn上找到我，这可能真的是找到我的最好地方，并展示他们提供的一些服务以及我所做的一些工作。那是尼古拉斯·斯托克林，S-T-O-C-K-L-I-N-G。你可以在LinkedIn上找到我。我会非常乐意提供帮助。完美。非常感谢。我会在节目说明和视频描述中链接LinkedIn。非常感谢你的时间以及你在支持人们度过他们生命中非常脆弱的时期所做的工作，尼古拉斯。非常感谢。这是一个非常有趣的讨论。我认为这是一件希望对各种人，在他们职业培训的各个阶段都有帮助的事情。绝对会有。再次感谢你的时间。一切顺利。你也是。再次非常感谢我的嘉宾，尼古拉斯·斯托克林。请务必去LinkedIn上查看他。如果你正在为执业能力而挣扎，他确实是风暴中的安全港。
to practice concerns. This was not my first chat with Nicholas. We did speak earlier more generically about fitness to practice for HCPC registered clinicians and you can check those details out on screen. If you are an aspiring psychologist yourself and even if you are a trainee psychologist, you might well find the aspiring psychologist membership helpful. Some people do choose to stay in the membership during training because they really welcome that kind of personal approach, support and kind of compassion from their peers as well. We've also been trialing, doing some one-to-one time included in the membership at no extra cost. So please do keep your eyes peeled on the page www. Aspiring hyphen Psychology.
这并不是我第一次与尼古拉斯聊天。我们之前更笼统地谈论过HCPC注册临床医生的执业能力，你可以在屏幕上查看这些详细信息。如果你自己是一位有抱负的心理学家，即使你是一位实习心理学家，你可能也会发现有抱负的心理学家会员资格很有帮助。有些人确实选择在培训期间留在会员资格中，因为他们非常欢迎那种来自同龄人的个人方法、支持和同情。我们还一直在尝试在会员资格中包含一对一的时间，无需额外费用。所以请务必留意页面 www. Aspiring hyphen Psychology.
ologist.co.uk for more information or if you've got any questions you can reach out to me at any time or on social media where I'm Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
ologist.co.uk 获取更多信息，或者如果你有任何问题，你可以随时联系我，或者在社交媒体上联系我，我在那里到处都是玛丽安·特伦特博士。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子以发表评论。